ciao benvenuti in un nuovissimo video mi
raccomando iscrivetevi al canale è molto
molto importante per me ci stiamo
avvicinando al milione e quindi ho
bisogno anche di voi
partiamo subito guarda un po uno deve
arrivare a 60 anni a fare le elezioni su
internet mamma antonio viri nell'aiutare
non capisco niente professoressa non c'è
problema glielo insegno io oggi mi
sentono allora iniziamo a fare qua
l'appello astigiano presente
buongiorno anche a lei è bernardello
presente allora oggi parleremo di
romanticismo e mi raccomando fate
attenzione disattivato intorno
volevo approfittare prima che inizi la
dizione per ringraziarla perché non è da
tutti insomma essere così disponibili
cosa è stato questo rumor ha accusate
mio fratello scoppiato un palloncino
l'ora di attiviamo questo editor ragazzo
meno funziona provato in tutti i modi
ditelo alla provincia dunque questo
movimento che nasce alla fine del xviii
secolo dico io che cosa stava succedendo
ma io non miro vendola disattivate
questo mi crawford che sento tutto
quello che dite no vabbè marchigiana di
baselli ciao ragazzi io pubblico alle
storie mi scusi prof non ho capito molto
bene l'ultimo punto fuori spiegarli per
favore ma certamente giada guarda non
c'è problema anzi volevo proprio
riprendere quel quell'argomento grazie
anzi per avermelo ricordato raggiata che
fa la china oppure durante le direzioni
cioè ti prego
oma 16 mag basta basta non scrivo più
ragazzi prima che te che temi mi faccia
ricoverare ve lo chiedo per l'ultima
volta disattivata i microfoni perché o
il vostro casinò nella testa è mi sto
premendo proprio e non riesco più
neanche pensare posso andare in bagno
come no
ce la dà lo stesso no lui pensa gravity
camera si è spenta
nola che non avete capito sotta pensando
la camera la scrivania il computer di
post it così quando mi interroga leggo e
basta come dicevo alla fine del libro
trovate tutte le risposte
la professor salve salve professoressa
sono la mamma di marina sull salve
signora siccome sta bene bene certo lei
ma è mai la situazione un po è che ci
dobbiamo fare le sue bambine tutto bene
anche loro studiano da casa i bagni dove
ne sia anche loro e non ho mai né si sta
impegnando molto hard il io stavo giusto
facendo lezione quindi a deve iniziare
la legge abbado scusi se può per favore
chiamare sua figlia iniziamo tanti
saluti a lei alla famiglia grazie marina
no vabbè quant'è bello io lo amo adesso
ho un idea a farci una foto faccio lo
screenshot e poi mi faccio la
gigantografia mi attende in camera
disattiviamo questi micropolis io no
scusi prova ragione mi è passato il
gatto sulla tastiera adesso disattivo
subito allora ragazzi tutto pronto io
attivo la videocamera pena l'attivo
dovete subito registrare la sua razione
perché voglio vedere che faccia fa
perché capito se lui fa la faccia tipo
wow allora c'è in piazza basta di tutto
sto casino non riesco a concentrarmi sto
studiando allora ragazzi non ve lo dico
più disattivate questi microfoni perché
in queste condizioni noi che avete
sentito si disattiva suo microfono
se in casa veri mi parli un attimo nel
romanticismo è visto che ho appena
spiegato è teoricamente dovrebbe saperlo
molto bene il romanticismo è un
movimento culturale musicale letterario
sviluppatosi qui miss e al principio
ravelli
ma se impazzita ma cos'è ma non è un in
centro esterni si sono allentate ma
perché si vede e si vede si conta ma
cosa pensi che stare a casa tua flop
sono nato a mio sì bueno siccome sei
stato molto attento l'ultima volta dimmi
che cosa abbiamo studiato aki stop prof
ma si aspetti un attimo ma più o meno
che pagina era questo argomento la corsa
ti serve sapere in che pagina è dovresti
saperlo no l'uomo così giusto per fare
mente locale
e l'ho studiato sia allora lost
artículos indeterminato determinato spal
dell'ampia del sostantivo e tu pensi
grecia cretina è che non mi rendo conto
che tu stai leggendo poi ancora che
bordo della lezione mostrate disattivi
un paradosso disattivi il microfono e
videocamera e poi fai quello che vuoi
allora outfit di luigi è una cosa
improponibile andré come al solito cioè
troppo stiloso sorvoliamo sui lati della
prof
questo golfino cioè deve essere proposta
di quindi proprio odorano di naftalina
c'è una roba decente
sì se le chiedessi allora di parlarmi di
carducci
non sento bene
futia termico che vedere la lezione ai
già finita ora torno a dormire
eccoci arrivati alla fine del video
spero tantissimo che vi sia piaciuto
fatemi sapere con un commento qui sotto
in quali di queste tipologie vi siete
ritrovati condividetelo nelle chart con
i vostri compagni di classe
vi mando un bacione ci vediamo al
prossimo b
video ciao